The Mother of Dragons hasn't been the same
since she conquered Westeros . Ever since
Emilia Clarke wrapped up her role as Daenerys
Targaryen on HBO's hit series Game of Thrones,
she has spoken out about some of the tougher
moments she faced both on and off screen.
Throughout aher incredibly challenging, decade-long
role, the actress survived plenty of harrowing
times, no matter how much fame and acclaim
she racked up.
In the time since Game of Thrones came to
a fiery conclusion, Emilia Clarke has been
extraordinarily forthcoming about some of
the biggest struggles she dealt with during
filming.
In short, it's not hard to understand why
she hasn't fully recovered from Game of Thrones.
As a fresh-faced star on a huge HBO show,
Emilia Clarke seemed destined for stardom
thanks to her performance as Daenerys.
However, it wasn't until the spring of 2019
that fans realized just how much personal
comfort she truly sacrificed for the role.
In a New Yorker piece that ran in March of
that year, Clarke admitted that she suffered
two debilitating brain injuries while filming
the first two seasons of Game of Thrones,
both of which could have ended her career
and life.
After experiencing a serious brain aneurysm
right after she wrapped filming on the show's
freshman season, Clarke thankfully recovered,
but was left frightened, depressed, and anxious
about whether or not she would be able to
continue working.
The actress suffered from aphasia, a condition
that renders one unable to speak correctly,
in the aftermath of the first aneurysm.
During the show's second season, she suffered
from serious anxiety and collapsed once, then
endured yet another aneurysm after the third
season of Thrones wrapped.
At that time, Clarke was also preparing for
her Broadway debut in Breakfast at Tiffany's.
Clarke's co-stars, including Khal Drogo actor
Jason Momoa, were incredibly supportive of
her speaking out about what she had been through,
but the experience was terrifying for the
young actress.
In the same article, Clarke revealed that
she sank to a dark place after her second
aneurysm:
"All hope receded.
I felt like a shell of myself.
So much so that I now have a hard time remembering
those dark days in much detail.
My mind has blocked them out.
But I do remember being convinced that I wasn't
going to live."
Beyond her frightening offscreen medical struggles,
Emilia Clarke also endured plenty of hardships
on the set of Game of Thrones.
As a star of a show that was routinely called
out for unnecessary nudity, Clarke was unsurprisingly
asked to perform a number of nude scenes.
She was often uncomfortable on set and unsure
if she could say no until later seasons, once
she gained more clout and recognition.
In November 2019, she admitted that some of
her nude scenes were difficult to handle,
particularly because she felt both powerless
and pressured as a young performer on the
cusp of international stardom.
However, with or without the nude scenes,
Clarke also suffered from serious imposter
syndrome on the set of Thrones during the
show's early seasons.
As she told Dax Shepard on his podcast Armchair
Expert:
"Regardless of if there were nudity or not,
I would have spent that first season thinking,
'I'm not worthy of requiring anything, I'm
not worthy of needing anything at all."
Beyond that, Daenerys Targaryen's journey
left Emilia Clarke understandably shaken as
well.
The actress spent years playing her character
as a virtuous, justice-driven young queen
hell-bent on reclaiming her family's ancestral
throne.
That's why it shocked Clarke just as much
as anyone else when Daenerys torched King's
Landing from atop her largest dragon in the
final season.
The decision led to her murdering countless
innocent civilians in her quest to take the
Iron Throne.
Clarke admitted that upon reading the script
and learning of the big Daenerys twist, she
had to walk around the streets of London just
to process the character's personal arc.
That shock was undoubtedly made even worse,
considering that after sacking King's Landing,
Dany doesn't make it to the Iron Throne.
Instead, she's assassinated by her nephew-lover
Jon Snow.
Clarke will likely always be associated with
Daenerys Targaryen, but even Game of Thrones'
biggest fans should recognize the sacrifices
the actor made for this enormous, unforgettable
role.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.